let's get right into audience questions
today
last set of audience questions before
our little vacation
and then we'll be back and we'll take
more of them cancel culture
got a very interesting question we know
that david
that the right hates cancel culture
supposedly
but how do they believe it should be
fixed anyway
isn't any quote solution authoritarian
by da
by definition uh this is a great point
essentially all answers for how the
right wants to
fix the problem of cancel culture are
extremely authoritarian
other than just like culture changing
where people don't say when they don't
like something anymore
which i don't know how you achieve um
i don't know how you would ban cancel
culture or the fact that actions have
consequences and
sometimes people will tweet about it
sometimes people will tell a business
i'm not going to buy your product
because of this or that or the other
thing that
you as a company said or one of your
employees said or whatever
any of those actions would be
authoritarian and they would be
against what they claim their views
to be remember the right says they're
about free speech and people getting to
say what they want and business is not
being regulated
any way that you try to fix what they
define as cancel culture would either
require
limiting businesses regulating
businesses somehow so they
can't act on whatever information they
want assuming it's not illegal like
someone's race or religion
to say we don't want to work with you
anymore you're fired or whatever that's
very heavy-handed authoritarian business
regulation which the right claims to be
against uh saying people don't have the
right
to tweet their displeasure at what a
celebrity or a business said
they don't have the right to announce
and carry out
a boycott on a business because that's
what they want to do it's all
insanely authoritarian there
would be no conceivable legislative
solution
to quote cancel culture that wouldn't
violate or in some other ways limit
violate the first amendment or limit
speech
so what you have to once you understand
there's no legislative way to deal with
cancel culture
you have to realize that the continued
demands from the right to deal with
cancer culture
either go against the very first
amendment they claim to defend
or are merely pandering and that's one
of the most important things i think
that we can take away from this
discussion which is that many of these
right-wingers and some on the left
who are talking about cancel culture not
as something that happens infrequently
and that we should really and think
about and evaluate
and say what what makes sense
when they are talking about it they
don't even really want a solution
in the sense that they know there isn't
going to be one this is just a cultural
reality elections
uh rather i'm sorry speech elections do
have consequences
speech has consequences and those
consequences in most cases are also
protected by the first amendment as far
as the government is involved
by business freedom when businesses are
involved
etc now we can't ignore
the huge hypocrisy from the right on
this issue
who are the two biggest victims of
cancellation that you can think of
over the last 20 years for me they're
clear it's the dixie chicks
who were are a country music
uh uh band but when they came out
against george w
bush's foreign policy the right which is
very intertwined with country music
canceled them they were blacklisted from
so many radio stations
and the right said we're dixie chicks
are over
colin kaepernick these two biggest
instances of these cancellations that
the right claims to be against were done
by the right and then you had people
throwing you know
keurigs out the window um starbucks was
bad
the nfl for the kneeling uh amazon for
saying we're not gonna host parlor
um you know it go taylor swift when she
came out and took political positions
the right loves to cancel people using
their terminology but they claim to be
against it and so this entire thing is
a ruse now as i talked about last week
during during our interview um
with with professor cavallic
just because we can identify some
instances where someone was wrongly
shamed or fired doesn't mean we call
this an epidemic and he actually agreed
with me
on that issue and um you bring me
uh a wrong decision that was made and if
it was indeed made wrongly i'll be right
there with you it's no no problem
whatsoever
but we can't allow these right wingers
to claim they're against cancel culture
when they're some of the biggest
cancelers look at what republicans did
to cindy mccain
cindy mccain the widow of the late
senator john mccain
was censured because she didn't want to
vote for trump she wasn't voting for
trump
they are complete and total hypocrites
and this is really getting to the key
thing which is any solution
that they would propose would be
extraordinarily authoritarian and
arguably against the first amendment
and many of them don't really want
solutions they just want to pander and
unfortunately
it's working very well they're getting a
lot of mileage out of this dr
seuss cancel culture stuff what if you
could read
10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently checked
out the book podcast marketing strategy
by daniel rolls and kieran rogers and
so useful so particularly applicable to
what i'm doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video